a few days ago Facebook proudly
announced that they'd achieved eight
billion video views a day that's really
impressive until you learned that in the
first quarter of 2015
seven hundred and twenty five of the
thousand most viewed videos on Facebook
was stolen amassing a total of 17
billion views sites and content
aggregators steal videos from YouTube to
go viral on Facebook these videos go
viral because Facebook is cheating they
rigged their algorithm so that videos
uploaded into their player are preferred
to youtube links because users should be
kept as long as possible on the site so
Facebook can show them as many ads as
possible this is after all their
business model but it also cheats when
it comes to views a view is counted
after three seconds even if the video is
muted which means that because of
autoplay if you scroll through your
timeline slowly enough you count as a
viewer that means engagement is terrible
compared to youtube views Facebook views
plummet after a few seconds because most
views are not real but large numbers are
impressive so Facebook keeps pretending
while this force to virality is weird
the real problem is the so-called
freebooting the stealing of videos since
facebook prefers its own player stolen
videos reach way more people than the
original lately this has happened to us
more and more often
the most recent example amassed 3.2
million views and 140 thousand shares in
two days while our own post just reached
100,000 people and got shared one
thousand times other creators are hit
even harder smart for every day's videos
gets tilled in constantly getting viewed
up to 17 million times but even this is
dwarfed by examples like Tyrese Gibson a
singer who steals viral videos like this
one with 86 million views on his
Facebook page he adds a link to buy his
music too he's not alone in this a whole
group of people have built their online
presence around stealing other people's
work this is really bad for independent
creators contrary to popular belief
stolen content gives creators close to
no exposure at all only the thief and
Facebook profit from this quality
content takes a lot of creativity time
and love in our case a single video
literally takes hundreds of hours to
make even wait with more than a million
subscribers are dependent on the ads and
exposure without ads and the support of
our generous patrons we could not make
videos for a small creator a viral video
can mean the difference between a career
and a hobby on YouTube this kind of
theft is not a problem because they have
major safeguards that protect content
from being stolen
although the Content ID system is far
from perfect especially for film critics
and gamers Facebook on the other hand
pretends everything is fine and
constantly announces one milestone after
the other but things are not fine let's
look at the process of claiming your
copyright on Facebook in the last year 1
get an email or tweet from a fan that
gives you a direct link to your video
it's not possible to search for your
videos on Facebook yourself you depend
on luck to find your stolen videos to
search for facebook copyright
infringement on Google because it's
actually faster this way 3 fill out an
annoyingly long contact form before
watch the views on your Snowden videos
rise 5 Facebook finally pulls the video
conveniently the video has already
gained a 99 percent of all the views it
will ever get the thief doesn't have to
fear any negative consequences at all
this is what successful creators have to
deal with constantly and on top of
losing out in terms of exposure and
money it just feels like a violation to
be treated like that in a recent
statement Facebook announced they want
to change but it's hard to take them
seriously when it still takes days for a
stolen viral video to be taken down and
Facebook does not share the profits made
from it at this point Facebook is not a
partner creators look forward to working
with they've built their video empire on
stolen content and disregard for
original content creators this is
absolutely unacceptable for a
corporation worth billions of dollars
Facebook is already testing various
monetization models that will give the
uploads 8 cart of the ad revenue which
with the current state of play is
troubling right now this is mainly being
tested with big media companies but as
creators we don't feel like we're being
asked or taken into consideration by the
giant that is Facebook
what can you as a viewer do to help here
if you spot stolen content on Facebook
make a comment linking to the original
content alert the original creator
because only they can file a copyright
aport share this video or the one done
by smarter every day we all want the
same thing a free internet that the
basis for creativity community and great
stuff we sincerely hope that Facebook
will soon become a partner instead an
obstacle to this goal for more in-depth
information we recommend this article by
Hank green and if you want to support us
in our endeavor to survive in the world
of online video and make more videos you
can do so on patreon calm